become a student a single d became one
guitarist nightmare and another's dream
without notice members of the
underground metal band Metallica
informed their guitarist Dave Mustaine
he was being thrown out of the group
that same day a young guitarist Kirk
Hammett barely in his 20s and member of
a band called Exodus was given the job
thrown right into a new life he
performed his first show with the band a
few days later Kirk came to a humbling
realization that despite his years of
playing guitar and being invited to join
Metallica he wasn't as good as he'd like
to be despite joining his dream group
and turning professional Kirk insisted
that he needed more instruction that he
was still a student Joe Satriani the man
hamin choses his instructor would
himself go on to become known as one of
the best guitar players of all time sat
giannis plain style made him an unusual
choice for him that was the point kirk
wanted to learn what he didn't know
Satriani explained that what separated
heaven from the others was his
willingness to endure the type of
instruction they wouldn't such Rihanna's
system was clear there would be weekly
lessons that these lessons must be
learned and if they weren't that Hammond
was wasting everyone's time and needn't
bother to come back for the next two
years perv did as satriani required
returning every week for objective
feedback judgment and grilling even
after that two-year study period who
Satriani licks and riffs he'd been
working on each time he improved as a
player and as an artist the result no
matter what your musical tastes happen
abhi was that Hamid became one of the
great metal guitarist in the world
taking flash metal from an underground
movement into a thriving global musical
genre think about what hemet could have
done what we might have done in his
position where we to suddenly find
ourselves a rock star the temptations to
think I've made it I've arrived they
tossed the other guy because he's not as
good as I am they chose me because I
have what it takes had he done that we
probably never have heard of him or the
bank there are after all plenty of
Forgotten metal group in the 1980s you
can't learn if you think you already
know become a student